we are indeed with young staff Duda
after uh his draw against Fabiano
caruana first of all welcome to the show
if not for that accident against Richie
report this would have been more or less
a normal tournament 50 now you're on
minus one how how did you assess that
game and how did you try to bounce back
what did you do to bounce back after
that accident uh yeah indeed the game
against report was terrible
um yeah I mean I totally into the game
missed this idea King Tito I mean the
move itself and because I thought it's
just going to trade everything and and
draw but after King Detroit was suddenly
very tricky yeah maybe showband game so
um yeah and I didn't have it the time
also against that I think I uh I
completely outplayed him but um then I
have some some hallucination because I
fought after 91 Ruby too I can drop the
Rook actually I mean give out the
exchange and then I think if you can see
freaking Sito but then here's of course
rookie one I mean and after that I see
one uh Ruby tour I mean it was like no
Advantage whatsoever
so um yeah it's a bit a bit annoying of
course
um yeah but what to do yeah I mean you
have to keep going yeah yeah today also
another brilliancy because I
foreign
yeah it is the move of course
um yeah what's coming what can I say I
mean but you took only five and sure he
was blitzing out your moves you looked a
little bit disappointed but this was
quite a funny moment because Jan was
walking around and he saw the position
saw Fabi played Knight C5 and then he
started looking probably calculating
Bishop takes H7
um then understanding that it simply
doesn't work were you surprised about
this move 95 me yes because F5 was
played before another actually I
considered almost only 95 here we're
black so
um yeah seven I guess it doesn't work
seven King H6 and neither five I guess
yeah
foreign
both of them did you spend any time
calculating it or you were like okay
yeah I had it a little bit Yeah but um I
didn't believe anything I mean with uh
19b1 it's like uh never really working I
guess for me yeah so
um another line that we're calculating
was Knight G5 did you consider this
uh not really I was
um kind of looking to play very sorry
you know and at this point and um
though
just to try to pull the brakes uh
make make a draw yeah and here actually
I mean I thought uh
like its new position for me but
actually after this d65 tx5 I had this
digital video that I must have seen this
before this is very perpetual
um
yeah so after night's h3g takes H3 Queen
G5 is one also Queen F5
is the movie other than there is Queen
E2 I think
and the point is that after F6 there is
Queen A2 tracker which is very important
because otherwise I think I'm worse and
through V6 Rook A1 and
yeah again like FTX 5.834 yeah
and pretty much Perpetual yeah so I
guess so I guess I guess it was
um
I mean the result is not so bad of
course but um like the feeling the
tastes after this game is like uh I mean
it's very positive game and I want to
forget I guess despite uh sure a
disappointing result up to this point
for you for your standards how do you
like the atmosphere here in Bucharest
how do you like the organization talk to
us about that yeah I mean it's nice to
remember for sure but you are always
kind of biased I mean you know you play
well then everything is you know so
great yeah and if you're done then you
know he would
don't feel the same way but still I
can't really complain I mean everything
is top-notch so
um yeah it's nice still for rounds to
recover and get back get some positive
vibes from your results thank you very
much ashita for joining us and we'll see
you in the rest of the games yeah thank
you thank you Chris too then thank you
uh Duda indeed